Hey youtubers it's Charlie and today must
be a Star Wars day because there was a ton
of Episode 7 info that dropped. There's the
new stormtrooper designs, the supposed villains,
the main villain and even some plot details.
Lucasfilm has officialy said nothing about
it all, but this video will be a breakdown
of everything. And I'll be sure to mention
which rumors are more likely. I don't necessarily
consider it spoilers if it's just a rumor,
but just in case I'll remind everyone when
we get there. My friends also did a podcast
with Rian Johnson who’s directing Episode
8. So I’ll also mention what he said about
the movie.
If you're just finding me for the first time
I'm going to be doing weekly Rebels and movie
videos pretty soon so be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
So pretty much confirmed stuff first, the
new Stormtrooper designs. Just like with the
original trilogy there are variations for
the normal armor and for desert climate. Remember,
part of the movie will be on Tatooine.
It’s just a much sleeker modernized design.
I know a lot of you on twitter were asking
why there was a need to update the classic
design. Really I think it’s just JJ Abrams
visually conveying that a lot of time has
passed and certain things have evolved. Everything
is really close to what you remember, it just
looks like a few things have been updated
as tech evolved. Episode 7 is supposed to
take place about 30 years after Return of
The Jedi. Just to put some scale on it.
A lot of you are also asking about what the
Empire’s role is in the new trilogy and
what’s changed since the Battle of Endor.
Yes, shit went down and the Empire got it’s
ass handed to it. But the Empire didn’t
take all of their resources to Endor. There’s
still millions of Imperial soldiers all over
the galaxy with their own fleets.
When I get to the villain and potential spoilers
I’ll talk about it more specifically, but
essentially the Empire is still around, some
of the brass at the top has changed. It’s
like Walmart. Just because the executives
go away doesn’t mean new ones don’t step
in to fill the vacuum. The bureaucracy of
the Empire was all about advancement. There’s
always someone younger and more evil ready
to steal your job when you get thrown down
an elevator shaft.
So spoiler portion for the villains. This
is just a rumor, but all the same just skip
forward in the video like 45 seconds if you
don’t want to know anything. Since you guys
requested it, I’ll add this little text
bug too while spoilers are still going on.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
The big rumor is that a bunch of crewmembers
from the movie were being laid off recently
and it led to some villain leaks. The details
are that The Inquisitors are the big antagonists
and the main villain is the head inquisitor.
There’s no info about his name or if he’s
tied to the Inquisitor in Star Wars Rebels,
but supposedly, that picture JJ Abrams tweeted
last week, the one with the droid hand, belonged
to the main villain. He’s a mostly cybernetic
sith inquisitor.
This is supposedly an image of him. No idea
if this is fan made or real concept art. But
it’s been sweeping the interwebs all morning.
If it’s true, picture him as being darker
grittier version of Darth Vader. Like when
Vader’s headpiece came off and you could
see more machine parts covering his skull.
It makes sense that JJ Abrams would want a
more terrifying villain. But the big question
is, are they going to humanize him like they
did with Darth Vader in Empire and Return
of the Jedi?
There’s no info saying who the villain was
before he became a cybernetic Sith Inquisitor.
But here’s why I think this rumor is true.
Or partially true. Using the Inquisitors in
the new films lines up with what Lucasfilm
has said about Rebels being canon and characters
from the cartoon being featured in the films.
More spoiler rumors. Supposedly there will
also be Darth Vader flashbacks that tie in
with the Sith Inquisitors. Luke Skywalker
is supposed to have a monologue in flashback
explaining how Vader started using the Inquisitors
to hunt down Jedi. Which is already happening
in the cartoon this fall.
The reason this is a big deal is it means
Vader really does have a small role in the
new films. He’s dead though, they’re not
changing that. But they are changing the rule
of two. As in the Inquisitors will be retconned
into the original trilogy.
It’s just a way for them to explain, hey
“This group of bad guys have been working
with Vader and the Emperor the whole time”
and just because Vader and the Emperor died,
it doesn’t mean the Inquisitors stopped
what they were doing.
They’d just seize control of the Empire
and continue the mission. Supposedly Leia
also gets flashbacks to Alderaan that tie
in with them too. That’s why Carrie Fisher’s
real life daughter was cast in the movie.
For a young leia flashback cameo.
All those villain flashback things are just
rumors right now. But they sound very plausible.
I’ll be doing weekly Rebels videos so as
long as you watch those videos and the tv
show you’ll be up to speed. That premiere’s
in october. Stay tuned for an exact date.
They haven’t announced it yet.
There was also some concept art for Han Solo
that posted. It’s old Han in his Hoth Gear.
It implies that we’ll see Hoth but most
of the talk was about how authentic the images
were. And whether or not the insignia on the
jacket was changed from the original in Empire
Strikes Back.
Supposedly there will be no New Republic in
the movie, so they’re still part of the
Rebellion. For those that didn’t read the
expanded universe novels. The New Republic
was the new government that rose from the
ashes of the Empire in the 10-15 years following
Return of The Jedi.
They are ditching a lot of the expanded universe
but it doesn’t mean we won’t see Mara
Jade or other big fan favorite characters.
There was some confirmation that on the Rebels
Cartoon they’re including the Rex droid
from the Original Disneyland Star Tours ride.
I kind of consider that to be expanded universe.
So there is hope for them including other
things.
On to Rian Johnson, for those that don’t
know. He was hired to write and direct Episode
8, scheduled for release in 2017. He just
did a podcast with my friend Emily at Grantland
and mentioned some really cool things going
on behind the scenes.
I’ll have a direct link to said podcast
in the description along with twitter links
for my friend. She’s one of the smartest
people I know and her podcast Girls in Hoodies
is a lot of fun. She does a lot of cool science
fiction and pop culture writing. So if you
do check it out be sure to leave them a nice
comment and tell them Emergency Awesome sent
you.
Rian Johnson has spent some time on set in
London while they’re filming Episode 7 and
he got super excited when he saw how much
of the movie is being shot on old school physical
sets. Like they’re building big X-Wings,
the Millenium Falcon. Just like they filmed
the original trilogy on.
It’s going to give it this amazing tactile
feeling that I think a lot of us felt was
missing from the prequels because most of
that was shot digitally on green screen.
If you look at some of the pictures and video
JJ Abrams has been posting you can see a lot
of real life creatures in the background.
It almost makes it feel like Jim Henson came
back to life and started making cool new Star
Wars puppets.
I think of all the things I’m hoping to
see in the new movie the most are Han and
Chewie old school scoundrel comedy. A couple
of twists on jokes from the original trilogy.
There’s a lesser rumor that Oscar Isaac
wins the Millenium Falcon from Han in a card
game and he has to get it back.
Luke Skywalker doing something really really
crazy with the force that we’ve never seen
before.
And Brienne of Tarth being a badass Inquisitor.
Like imagine Gwendoline Christie if she were
playing the Hound or even dial it up a notch
and make her freaking crazy like The Mountain.
I could talk all day about favorite stuff
I’d like to see. The hope is, that they
won’t play too much to nostalgia. They’ll
just focus on telling a new story using a
few familiar things.
I’m actually more excited for Rian Johnson’s
Empire Strikes Back. The second movie in a
trilogy is always the best. Most of the time
it’s the best. If you haven’t watched
any of his movies watch Looper and Brick.
Those are my favorites of his.
And be sure to listen to his podcast with
my friend. Feel free to embarrass her with
praise as long as it’s nice. Molly Lambert
is the other person on the podcast, I’ve
never met her in person but I’m also a big
fan of hers.
In case you missed it I was running a Star
Wars funko pop giveaway during Comic Con.
Congratulations to Shadow Artist. You get
your choice of star wars funko pop. I’ll
message you on your channel for details.
My next star wars video will be a review of
the big clip they posted. be sure to subscribe
to get it. They basically posted most of the
first episode for you to watch for free.
In the meantime click here for this week’s
Legend of Korra. Some shit went down. I’ll
add the annotation as soon as I post it. And
click here for my big Star Wars Rebels Breakdown.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!